uh all right let's try way
from nashville tennessee way
you were on the air hey david can you
hear me
yes i can oh hey um
so i guess uh i don't know i'm kind of
seeing this
new uh mississippi abortion bill
being pushed to the supreme court or the
supreme court's willing to examine it
i haven't looked at it yeah so it's
it's a new uh wall or bill from
mississippi that
has something to do with making
adjustments or
or limiting uh roe v wade and i just
don't see
like how that could i mean i see in a
reality
sense that the the conservative majority
could change it but like
what actual common sense is sort of
backing that because we've had
roe v wade in place for what 50 years
now
yeah this is the the idea here is not
that any one
bill is necessarily going to be what in
creates alternative precedent to change
roe v wade
it's they just want to keep hammering
hammering hammering and as soon as they
can get
anything favorable from the supreme
court it will then become the model
in more states to clamp down on abortion
so i get it you you look at this one
bill and you rightly say
this makes no sense we have roe v wade
but that's the whole point keep sending
things up to the supreme court
and try to slowly erode abortion rights
now i have to ask you
there's a hissing a clapping and horn
honking in the background
where are you right now describe it to
us
i'm really sorry i'm at work right now
i'm walking like in the back of the
warehouse
okay stay away from that stuff is there
a forklift
is there a forklift going by you right
now um
no but there's these big fans on the
roof that
are spinning and i'm real sorry about
that that's okay no i
you were well intentioned it's a great
question and the strategy is
keep hammering away and wait until you
can get something favorable from the
supreme court
and they just may because we have one of
the most right-wing supreme courts in a
long time
okay cool uh also one more question so
like
uh just watching like the sort of trash
propaganda and just bad faith from like
tarko carlson and
a lot of other fox news uh posts and
whatnot like
you think it's worth debating like like
a tucker carlson like is that gonna
would that even be worth time is it
worth it for who to debate tucker
carlson is the question
yeah i guess i guess that's that depends
but it's like i don't know
like you maybe i mean
sure maybe i mean you like on his show
you know here's the thing about all
these questions
it's like what's the format what's the
topic
what's the point who's the audience
where does it air there's no one
question
one answer to these different questions
i do think it's worth refuting bad
ideas and in that sense it's worth
refuting tucker carlson
all right well uh thanks for taking my
call david my pleasure all right we'll
let you get back to the warehouse there
just a lot going on there really a lot
happening but it's great to hear from so
many different people
why don't we go next to why don't we try
ruth from canada ruth you were on the
air
hi david hi where in canada are you
calling from
alberta oh beautiful that's a very
conservative area isn't it
yes unfortunately what's uh what's going
on yeah
so i have two questions um a few years
ago i think you
you hosted where you you produced a
bunch of
youtube clips about discussing logical
fallacies right
and things like that wondering if you
would do an
updated version of that well you know
i don't know if we're gonna update that
specifically
but we are now working uh this is a
exclusive to ruth from canada
announcement
um we are now looking at revitalizing
our sort of long-form deep dives and
really competing head-on with the trash
from
prageru and their bogus right-wing
explainers
so this is currently in development and
so i don't know if we're going to redo
the critical thinking series
but we're going to do all sorts of new
explainers
and um i think that there will be a lot
of things
to look forward to as far as that goes
looking forward to it um my second
question is uh mcconnell's just
confirmed and no surprise to anyone that
he wouldn't support an independent
investigation of the january 6th uh riot
yeah and the term independent i mean
it's really what we're talking about is
bipartisan right
democracy it's not so much independent
as bipartisan but yeah mitch mcconnell
said he's not going to support it
what what do you think the likely what
do you think the likelihood is that the
investigation will be able to move
forward
i actually think it will partially
because it's the house that would be
doing it and mitch mcconnell is in the
senate i know he still
wields power of course but there are
also at least 20 and maybe as many as 50
republicans who want to see it happen
so um i think that it i do believe it
will happen
awesome okay well love your show thanks
so much thanks ruth great to hear from
you
sorry you're in such a right-wing haven
in uh
in in canada there i've heard a lot of
things about alberta it can get pretty
brutal from what i've read
uh okay we're speaking to people via
discord davidpakman.com
discord is the place to find it let's go
next to sam from new york city you're on
the air
hey thanks so much for taking my call i
just wanted to ask you know i'm
all about abolishing the filibuster i'm
all about putting
pressure on you know joe manchin and the
like i think that is critical if we want
to get
progressive agenda passed especially
some of these voting rights bills but
you know
west virginia i think it's like the
second trumpiest
state in terms of just like you know
2020
vote share and so my concern is that
even though i don't agree with the more
moderate democrats i think
being too willing to criticize and oust
them from the party could just result in
a future where
to get 50 votes in the senate we're
looking at
36 47 48 as we sort of
fit any chance of having democratic
senators in purple or reddish states
goodbye
you know i totally agree with you i've
been making this point for years
and uh i know that there are people who
will get mad at this example
but here's the reality if you primary
joe manchin with bernie sanders and
democrats in west virginia pick bernie
over joe manchin
i don't see how the hell bernie then
wins the general senate election
in west virginia now maybe at some point
that specific example won't be a good
one
but i completely agree with you in
principle which is sometimes when when
democrats want to replace a centrist
democrat with a
further left democrat the most likely
scenario would be that it's just a
republican who wins and that's worse
no exactly i completely agree and i
guess i also worry in terms of getting
rid of the filibuster though i support
it if you do that in isolation
that's where it really concerns me
because in isolation
you eliminate the filibuster but we're
in a system
what is it republicans got 40 million or
democrats got 40 million more votes
in the most recent senate elections than
uh republicans yet the senate still
split when there's such a structural
disadvantage for democrats i think
creating a more majoritarian system
the senate when the senate is so biased
those republicans could be a recipe for
disaster yeah republicans
seem to support any real policy anyway i
completely agree with you
and uh the other important thing to
remember is
there are you know when we talk about
the obstacles to getting
x done rarely is there one blanket
explanation for why
x won't get done there's usually
different explanations for different
things
when you have a bill that joe biden
wants but two democratic senators don't
want
versus a bill that joe biden uh wants
but every senator wants but every
democratic senator wants but it requires
60 instead of 50 meaning it's now
on republicans every one of these
scenarios is a different scenario and
there's not one solution and the
solution of just
primary every centrist democrat and then
it'll solve all your problems i don't
think it's a realistic solution i think
it will
maybe solve some and create new problems
as well
totally would you mind if i asked one
last question go ahead by the way is
this sam cedar or a different
sam from new york city oh different
different okay got it okay i'm calling
actually you got it
um yeah what i was going to say is um i
was just wondering your take
one thing that really frustrates me is
how like american-centric
americans worldviews and political views
tend to be and just that all of our
focus
is always on domestic politics yeah
there are only
like huge british elections just earlier
this week and
there are crises happening across the
globe and i understand that a lot is
happening in the u.s and it's good to
pay attention but
what do you think is our responsibility
as americans who have the privilege to
have access to global news to stay up to
date on
not only international politics but the
domestic politics of other countries
yeah i mean um i think that i would
prioritize
if you if you find someone who pays no
attention to what's going on outside the
u.s
i would suggest first start paying
attention to what's going on
internationally
that would be a higher priority than
knowing the internal politics of other
countries if you if you say well pick
one to start with
i think it's very easy when you live in
a country like the united states that
dictates so much of global culture and
global technology and so many different
things
just to basically be in an island and
only pay attention
to what happens in the u.s i think it
leads to very narrow world views
um and i think it leads to people who
it it leads to that wing of the
republican party where we said hey
earlier this week europe announced it
would open to vaccinated people
and i said you know i don't think this
will be much of an incentive to the
anti-vaccine republicans because
they already think europe is just about
sissies and communists
there's a whole culture of people who
proactively are hostile
to the idea of what happens in other
countries mattering and you have to
change the culture around that
totally i think when you consider just
how crucial the role of our allies is
um and you look at the fact that all
right germany is going to have a new
chancellor
at the end of the year france has
elections next summer
a lot of things are going to change even
a lot of things that could impact
joe biden's ability to get his foreign
policy agenda done yeah we pay
very little attention but i agree with
you about the prioritization
all right my friend thank you for the
call i appreciate it
thank you so much take care all right
you too of really strong calls today i
have to tell you a lot of very
interesting topics